[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'actualités
locales voici les principaux titres en
images de ce 14 février 2010 est l'élu
d'opposition à magny les hameaux en
charge de la campagne est digital
d'alain juppé pendant la primaire de la
droite vient de rejoindre emmanuel
macron à nous expliquera dans un instant
les raisons de ce rallye là dans
l'actualité locale la librairie
solidaire de trappes ouvre à nouveau ses
portes au public c'est dorénavant la
ville qui se charge de la gestion de
l'établissement également outil de
réinsertion et puis c'est aujourd'hui la
saint valentin vous découvrirez une
belle histoire au cours de ce journal
celle de robert et colette riyom il y à
60 ans ils se disaient oui pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
ils viennent de renouveler leurs voeux
en mairie de fontenay le fleury en ce
jour de la saint valentin nous débutons
donc par une déclaration d'amour celle
d'or berges emmanuel macron l'élu
d'opposition les républicains magny les
hameaux en charge de la campagne et
digital d'alain juppé pendant la
primaire de la droite et a donc décidé
de se mettre en marche
aurore bergé bonsoir vous êtes en ligne
avec nous vous avez annoncé aujourd'hui
votre décision dans une tribune publiée
sur internet publié sur l'obs vous êtes
une jeune trentenaire vous êtes engagé à
droite depuis vos 16 ans pourquoi ce
ralliement aujourd'hui auprès d'emmanuel
macron alors sereinement n'a rien à voir
avec la saint valentin
plus sérieusement ça fait 14 ans à
droite a beaucoup évolué en politique
vous allez plusieurs choix soit vous
suffisait aveuglément la ligne du parti
quelle qu'elle soit quelles que soient
les circonstances
soit vous allez là où sont vos
conditions ça peut vous amener à
soutenir des gens sont différents mais
parce qu'ils incarnent les valeurs qui
sont les vôtres moi c'est le choix que
je fais j'essaie campagne ardemment
auprès d'alain juppé je persiste à
regretter qu'il n'ait pas été désigné
choisir un candidat pour cette élection
fut une ancienne mais comme hp n'est
plus candidat moi j'ai décidé de faire
un autre choix de qui n'est pas fluide
soutenir françois fillon se sont juste
et le soin de campagne les décisions et
ce sont les décisions les
positionnements prix par françois fillon
qui ont une incidence aujourd'hui sur ce
ralliement auprès d'emmanuel macron sans
parler bien évidemment des des affaires
aujourd'hui de la tourmente hausse
autour d'eux des emplois présumés
fictifs
écoutez moi tu voulais c'est tout le
paradoxe de là à dire que le moment
parce qu'il ya une primaire il faudrait
du jour au lendemain à arrêter de penser
qu'on a pensé pendant la campagne de la
primaire
mais moi ce que j'ai dit pendant la
primaire j'ai cru et notamment pendant
l'entre-deux tour de cette primaire où
on a eu quand même 2 millions différent
de la société qui se dégageait en scène
alain juppé que je souffrais et celle de
françois fillon et je peux pas dès le
lendemain en oublier ce en quoi je crois
et par exemple sur la question des
droits des femmes majeures qui est au
coeur de mon engagement que des années
j'ai travaillé extrêmement dur sur le
sujet ont douché quand même pas
extrêmement récente un engagement
clairement françois fillon a joué dans
des 8es sur un sujet qui pour moi
fondamental qui l'accepté pas m'amuser
et la souplesse et pas juste parce que
je manque d'un fonds de deux points la
tva
c'est une question de valeurs à 70 jours
de la présidentielle une dernière
question comment va se traduire ce
ralliement justement écoutez moi c'est
pas négocié de place entre l emmanuel
macron pour gagner je le souhaite
ardemment je manque un vrai risque
le front national puisse gagner cette
campagne je pense que le seul qui peut
nous en prémunir aujourd'hui s'appelle
emmanuel macron je pense que j'espère
qu'il ya une vraie dynamique va se
construire autour de lunel existe déjà
dans les finales les annuaires mars
c'est le premier engagement politique
extrêmement aussi que ça continue comme
ça la vie politique y compris dans notre
département
elle espère que le plus non plus de
faire fans vont se mettre en marche
merci aurore bergé je rappelle que vous
êtes élus et donc à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines actualité
économique à présent et le constructeur
automobile renault qui affiche une
croissance de son chiffre d'affaires de
13% record de ventes avec près de 3
millions de véhicules immatriculés
résultats qui a un impacte forcément sur
le technocentre située à guyancourt
écouter philippe brice montier c'est le
directeur interviewé par nicolas landry
la contribution du techno tonnes comme
vous le savez était de travailler sur le
design les études et la conception de la
gamme de renault que vous voyez
aujourd'hui dans la rue et qui est
accueilli comme vous le savez avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé à l'ensemble de
nos clients
les résultats de vendredi ils ont encore
une fois démontré bien entendu ces
excellents résultats vont nous permettre
de travailler sereinement sur tous les
projets que nous avons engagées ces
derniers mois nous avons aussi deux
grands projets qui sont le véhicule
connecté et le véhicule autonome
ces projets là une grâce à ces résultats
on va pouvoir continuer de les mener à
bien encore une fois en toute sérénité
sociale et attrape une réouverture très
attendue par les habitants c'est celle
de la librairie solidaire le
millefeuille la boutique est restée
fermée pendant sept longs mois suite à
la dissolution de l'association et qui
était en charge de sa gestion c'est
dorénavant la mairie qui pilote qui
coordonne l'ensemble le reportage d'anne
laure l'anguille
c'est jour de réouverture pour le
millefeuille à trappes l'association
bleu oxygène développement qui avait
créé cette librairie solidaire en 2006 a
dû fermer l'été dernier la mairie de
trappes a depuis repris la boutique on a
envie de recommencer
c'est à dire de revoir nos clients de
revoir nos habitués de revoir les gens
qui découvrent aussi donc le plaisir de
découvrir l'accès aux livres en fait
pour beaucoup dans ce quartier populaire
la librairie rencontre un véritable
succès hier déjà certains habitués se
précipitaient croyant qu'elle avait
rouvert son atout des livres à petits
prix grâce aux dons de médiathèque et de
particuliers qu'est ce qu'on vaut en
traitant de la cd rom ans
essentiellement man ou quasiment que des
romans
donc on va nous certains vont être mis à
la vente et certains vont être recyclés
en fait pour son fonctionnement la
librairie emploie neuf adultes en
réinsertion sous le statut d'agents
municipaux
un modèle que la responsable souhaite
voir répliquée dans d'autres villes moi
j'aimerais dans l'idéal c'est que le
lieu soit reconnue pour pour ce qu'il
est de façon plus large qu'on essaye
décès mais la librairie ça veut dire que
d'autres départements et l'idée en fait
de de reproduire en fait des dispositifs
et des lieux de ce type pour sa
réouverture la librairie ne change pas
de recette
le choix reste très variés parmi les
trente cinq mille ouvrages qu'elle
propose et c'est donc aujourd'hui la
s'en va longtemps nous allons partager
avec vous cette belle histoire celle de
robert et colette riyom ils ont fêté
leurs soixante ans de mariage en mairie
ils ont fêté cette cérémonie en
renouvelant leurs voeux reportage de
nicolas landry c'était le 9 février 1957
robert et colette se disaient oui pour
le meilleur et pour le pire et ce samedi
11 février 2017
ils sont revenus en mairie pour célébrer
leurs 60 ans de mariage avec beaucoup
d'émotion c'est au mariage de mon frère
donc en 1954 et ensuite on s'est connus
on s'effraie compter et on s'est marié
en 57
je pense que chez moi
vous connaissez bien les femmes aussi
elles attendent le premier pas le maire
adjoint jean-marie bora a présidé cette
cérémonie une opportunité et un moment
exceptionnel que ce soit les noces d'or
ou les noces de diamant ce qui est
encore plus rare c'est toujours le maire
qu'il le fait est là
le maire est en vacances on est en
pleines vacances scolaires
et c'est pour ça que étant l'élu
d'astreinte
j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir de
présider cette cérémonie des voisins des
proches et la famille étaient présents
et parmi eux la fille et la petite fille
de robert et colette
moi j'ai divorcé bain très très tôt pour
diverses raisons voilà aussi j'aurais
bien aimé un jour fêter mes soixante ans
de mariage je ne fêterai jamais quoi que
ce soit mais voilà ça m'inspire que on
sait mais je pense différemment il ya de
cela 50 60 ans qu'aujourd'hui
j'espère que si un jour je me marie je
ne pense pas je pourrais les faits été
moi même puisque en moyenne en sommes
arrivés à notre 30 ans 35 ans donc voilà
je suis plus à mes études en semences et
mon métier et où est ma passion qui va
passer quand même avant
avant ma future vie de famille et pour
la saint valentin le couple
soixantenaire a aussi un message pour
les plus jeunes
bakchich aime autant que nous c'est le
seul message qu'on peut passer pour eux
le rendez vous est pris le 9 février
2000 27 pour leurs 70 ans de mariage
[Musique]
chaque mardi nous vous proposons de
suivre et de rencontrer celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de flora saab a axé la
présidente des jeunes républicains dans
le département durant la campagne de la
primaire à la soutenu nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui elle fait face à la
tourmente dans laquelle est plongée
françois fillon le portrait est signée
nicolas kirillovitch donc ici on a de
nouveau une flamme à enlever
elle contrôle que les garages sont bien
fixées vérifier contrôler et assurer
pour s'éviter un éventuel trou d'air des
gestes nécessaires pour sa sécurité en
l'air et des notions qui peuvent être
utiles parfois en politique à
l'aérodrome du chat venez non loin de
villepreux flora sabbagh est comme chez
elle sur cette piste fréquenté pendant
près de quatre ans pour une passion qui
datent de l'enfance au compteur soixante
dix heures de vol et l'obtention d'un
brevet de base
voler c'est un véritable bol d'air c'est
ce qui permet de conserver un équilibre
c'est ce qui permet d'avoir des à côtés
de pouvoir un peu sortir la tête de la
politique est aussi qu'on vole et ben on
voit la france d'euros ça permet de
prendre un peu de hauteur et de voir nos
territoires qui sont magnifiques
un territoire magnifique flore assabah
connaît par coeur de feucherolles dans
les yvelines à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'ancienne
militante de l'uni jongle depuis ses 18
entre vie politique est étudiante
la politique c'est très prenant c'est
beaucoup de sacrifices personne ne m'a
forcé à le faire et forcément j'ai fait
un choix de vie qui m'oblige aussi et
bien apprendre de mon temps à ne pas
faire certaines activités que d'autres
jeunes de mon âge pourrait faire
je ne veux pas sortir tous les soirs
comme je voudrais le faire comme
certains jeunes mon âge peuvent le faire
c'est aussi un rythme de travail qui me
convient sinon je ne serais pas engagé
en politique
alors qu'on repart quoi nouvelle
campagne nouveaux objectifs
la politique justement il en est
question ce soir là au qg des
républicains des yvelines flora sabbagh
endosse alors le costume de chef
une réunion en pleine semaine pour son
des airs motiver des troupes déstabilisé
par la chaire fillon je sais que
certains jeunes ont pu ont pu avoir
effectivement un sentiment un sentiment
d'être déçus de par les sommes qui ont
été révélés mais il faut pas oublier que
derrière il ya le projet pour la france
qui est en cause et c'est un peut pas se
le permettre donc il va falloir qu'on se
mobilise
touché mais pas coulé la jeune
présidente des républicains 60,18
s'attend à des prochaines semaines
compliquées entre meetings réunions
publiques et tractage une campagne aux
allures de tactique militaire
on doit être présent sur le terrain on
doit ne pas lâcher le terrain
un millimètre de terrain on doit
toujours avancé ne pas reculer ne pas
laisser la place aux médias qui veulent
imposer un duel marine le pen
emmanuel macron on doit faire valoir le
programme de notre candidat parce que
jordi manuela qu'on n'a pas de programme
et aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'on doit
convoi faire valoir sur le sur le
terrain et pour ça on est déterminés et
on est motivé la motivation politique
flore assabah de la découverte en 2012
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle
à peine majeur et le bac en poche elle
s'engage pour défendre ses valeurs
travail méritait identité c'est vrai que
du fait que notre pays bascule dans le
socialisme ça a été aussi une envie de
porter nos idées pour que la droite
gagne les prochaines élections
et notamment on a conquis tous les
échelons et là aujourd'hui on est une
élection cruciale élection
présidentielle et j'espère profondément
qu'on va pouvoir voir la droite revenir
enfin à la tête de notre pays et pour
espérer revenir au pouvoir la droite
devra mobiliser la jeunesse il y a cinq
ans près de 20% des moins de 25 ans se
sont abstenus un chiffre qui pourrait
augmenter au regard de l'actualité
politique et pour terminer ce journal
les images de la délivrance pour éric
bellion le vendée globe s'est achevée
pour lui hier lundi 13 février en fin
d'après-midi le versailles et novice sur
ce tour du monde en solitaire sans
escale est arrivé aux sables d'olonne à
17h58 et 20 secondes fin du parcours
très compliqué le navigateur et eu un
problème ce week-end avec sa grand voile
avec son moteur il a aussi fait face à
des vents très puissants il termine à la
9e place de ce classement
les programmes se poursuivent sur tv
fils à retrouver sur notre site internet
et sur notre application un mobile très
belle soirée
[Musique]